in washington cbs news has confirmed
that a federal
search warrant was issued to north
carolina senator richard burr
it's part of a probe of financial moves
before the coronavirus outbreak
sent the markets plunging nancy cordes
is on capitol hill nancy what more do we
know
well anthony a u.s official confirms to
cbs news that the fbi
did seize senator burr's cell phone in
connection
with those stock sales now burr is the
chair of the powerful senate
intelligence committee and back in
january
he and other senators began to get
regular briefings
about the coronavirus crisis that was
brewing
in china then filings in mid-february
showed that burr
sold up to roughly 1.7 million dollars
in stock now by that time the public
knew about the coronavirus threat
but several days before the sales burr
had written an op-ed assuring americans
that the u.s was prepared for a pandemic
days after his sales he gave a speech
saying that the virus
could have major consequences here now
there's a law called the stock act that
prohibits members of congress from using
non-public information they obtain
through their official positions
for personal benefit back in 2012 burr
was one of three senators
who voted against it now burr attended a
hearing with the nation's leading
health experts earlier this week you see
him there
he has said he relied solely on public
news reports
when he sold the stocks according to a
spokesperson for bird the senator filed
a financial disclosure form
about the transactions several weeks
before
the u.s financial markets showed signs
of volatility
due to the coronavirus outbreak he has
since asked the senate ethics committee
to review
his trades and now it appears that the
fbi
is reviewing those trades too doj
and the senator's office have declined
to comment we also reached out to burr's
attorney
but have not heard back yet it is
important to note tony
that no charges have been filed at this
point
and we will follow the investigation
wherever it leads nancy thank you very
much